?
>> HOW AWFUL THAT A GOOD
SAMARITAN WAS JUST TRYING TO
HELP THEM OUT AND ENDED UP DEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AMARA
WALKER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> THIS MORNING RUSSIAN
OPPOSITION LEADER ALEXEI NAVALNY
IS BACK IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT,
BUT BEFORE HE WENT BACK IN HE
SPOKE OUT.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> Translator: I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT I GOT A LITTLE BIT
LONELY IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
AND IT IS JUST AMAZING TO ME TO
SEE SO MANY PEOPLE.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO I AM IN
CONTACT WITH ARE THE ONES WHO
HAND ME THE FOOD AND OF COURSE,
MY FAVORITE HEAD OF THE UNIT WHO
SITS NEXT TO ME FILMING.
>> NAVALNY WITH SOME SORT OF
HUMOR CRACKING EVEN A SLIGHT
SMILE AS HE SPOKE WITH
JOURNALISTS INSIDE A MOSCOW
COURT THIS MORNING.
IN ADDITION TO HIS NEW
PUNISHMENT THERE ARE ALSO NEW
REPORTS OF HIM BEING LIMITED
FOOD AND POSSIBLY EVEN POISONED
AGAIN WHILE IN JAIL.
ACCORDING TO HIS SPOKESPERSON
NAVALNY WILL NOW SPEND A TOTAL
OF 158 DAYS IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT FOR THIS ROUND OF
PUNISHMENT.
COMPARE THAT TO A TYPICAL
SOLITARY SENTENCE IN MOSCOW
WHICH IS USUALLY NO MORE THAN 15
DAYS.
CNN'S JIM SCIUTTO JOINS US NOW
BECAUSE YOU HAD AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
YOU SPOKE WITH NAVALNY'S
DAUGHTER ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
WHAT DOES SHE TELL YOU ABOUT
WHAT HE'S FACING IN PRISON NOW?
>> LISTEN, THE FIRST POINT DASHA
WILL MAKE AND HER FAMILY IS THAT
IN THEIR VIEW THIS IS NOT A
LEGAL PROCESS AT ALL IN RUSSIA,
THAT THERE IS A DIRECT THROUGH
LINE FROM THE JUDICIARY SYSTEM
THERE TO THE KREMLIN AND THAT
HEARINGS, ET CETERA, THE
OUTCOMES FROM THE FAMILY'S
PERSPECTIVE ARE KNOWN THAT PUTIN
WANTS TO TIGHTEN THE GRIP AROUND
HIM AND PUNISH HIM FURTHER, EVEN
MORE THAN IT'S ALREADY DONE SO
THAT'S THE VIEW OF THE LEGAL
PROCESS AND THEN YOU HAVE HIS
DAY TO DAY LIFE AND NOT JUST
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, BUT DASHA
TOLD ME YESTERDAY THAT THEY NOW
UNDERSTAND HIS FOOD IS BEING
LIMITED IN PRISON AND THAT IS A
GREAT CONCERN TO THEM BECAUSE
OVERALL THEY CONTINUE TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HIS HEALTH AS
HIS WEIGHT HAS BEEN DROPPING.
HAVE A LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID
TO ME.
>> ONE OF MY DAD'S ATTORNEYS HAS
CONFIRMED THAT ACCORDING TO THE
NEW RULES THAT THEY SPECIFICALLY
DREW UP FOR MY DAD, HE IS NOW
ONLY LIMITED TO THE AMOUNT OF
FOOD THAT HE CAN PURCHASE IN THE
CANTEEN WHICH DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THIS BIG OF A PROBLEM, BUT THE
FOOD IN THE RUSSIAN PRISON
SYSTEM WAS BAD AND MY DAD HAS
HAD PROBLEMS WITH LOSING WEIGHT,
AND NOW THE SITUATION HAS GOTTEN
SO RIDICULOUS THAT HE BUYS THE
FOOD WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, OATS
AND NOTHING LUXURIOUS AND HE
BUYS OATS AND SHOWN TO HIM AND
JUST DESTROYED.
SO HE CAN'T EAT.
>> THEY DESTROY THE FOOD IN
FRONT OF HIM.
THIS IS DELIBERATE, RIGHT?
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT IMPACTING
HIS HEALTH, BUT IT'S DEMEANING.
BUY THE FOOD, WHAT LITTLE YOU
CAN AND WE'LL LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF FOOD YOU CAN BUY AND WE'LL
DESTROY IT IN FRONT OF YOU AND
THAT'S BEEN PART OF HIS
EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT, KATE.
>> THERE ARE VERY REAL AND
ONGOING CONCERNS ABOUT HIS
HEALTH, BUT WHAT IS NEXT FOR
HIM?
WHAT DOES HIS FAMILY THINK AND
ALSO JUST OVERALL AS WE WATCHED
THIS CARRY ON FOR YEARS NOW,
WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S PLANS ARE
FOR HIM?
>> THEIR CONCERN IS THAT IT'S
JUST ENDLESS, THAT HE'LL BE PUT
IN PRISON.
FIRST OF ALL, RUSSIA HAS WELL
DOCUMENTED IN THE DOCUMENTARY
"NAVALNY" TRIED TO KILL HIM WITH
NOVICHOK AND ONLY THROUGH THE
WORK OF DOCTORS DID HE SURVIVE
THAT AND HE WAS BROUGHT BACK TO
RUSSIA AND PUT IN PRISON FOR
MORE THAN TEN YEARS AND NOW YOU
HAVE ANOTHER TRIAL THAT'S LIKELY
TO EXTEND THAT STAY AND WHILE
HE'S IN PRISON HAVING HIS FOOD
LIMITED AS WELL AS CONCERNS THAT
THEY MIGHT TRY TO POISON HIM
AGAIN.
THE FAMILY'S CONCERN THAT HE'LL
NEVER GET OUT THAT PUTIN'S
INTENTION IS THAT HE DIES IN
PRISON AND REALLY THEIR ONLY
HOPE IS THAT PUTIN GOES BEFORE
HE DOES AND THAT'S THE S